>>My name is Olivia.
I'm seventeen and I've lived
in San Francisco my whole life.
I don't have a computer.
I don't always have a cell phone
but technology is like my lifeline.
The places I go to get access for
computers is either at school,
downstairs in my building, or
if I'm at a friend's house.
>>Candace: How many of you guys have
access to a computer in your home?
Okay.
>>Olivia: My school is
a continuation school,
or you could call it credit recovery.
>>Candace: How many
of you guys know how
to upload videos and upload pictures?
Okay. So before I give you guys an
assignment, we can actually all go
to the computer lab, and then whoever
knows how to do it can demonstrate.
>>I think about one
third of the students
in the classroom have access
to a computer at home.
>>If I gave you guys an
assignment like create a video,
would you do something like
that, as a final project?
>>Kyle: Find the area of one side.
>>The majority of them don't
have access to machines.
The assumption is, "Well, they
don't know how to use them then."
Well, as soon as you plop them
down in front of a computer,
they're on MySpace, they're going
to Facebook, they're sending emails.
I mean, so it's clear
that they've had access.
>>I'd say Olivia, I think she's kind
of savvy and I think she's curious
about learning new things.
And I think soon, you're going
to have high school classes
and other jobs and things
like that where a main form
of communication will be through
IMing and social networking.
>>Olivia: This is my MySpace page.
I got like a picture right
here, so a little context of me.
Pictures, a music video,
me and my sister.
Miscellaneous comments
that people sent me.
And my mom, she's a big
poker fan, so she wanted me
to do her page all poker.
So I got these little falling aces.
This profile, like the
background, we made it ourselves
and I put all the family on here.
It's pretty cool.
And I made a MySpace
for my mentor Dawn.
>>Yeah, he's cute.
>>Dawn: Yeah.
>>Olivia: He's at the--
>>Dawn: Olivia and I
were matched back in--
oh my goodness, it'll be
eight years in November.
>>Were we at Pier Thirty Nine?
Was that where we were,
having dinner?
Where were we?
>>I'm her big sister in the Big
Sister, Big Brother program.
>>Olivia: Dawn, she's just
a real understanding person
and no matter what
I was going through,
she was always there to
just like back me up.
>>Dawn: She's amazingly creative.
She's helped me with my MySpace page,
which I never would've had before.
>>Olivia: And so one day, I was all
like, "Let's make you a MySpace,"
and she was like, "I
really don't need one."
And I was like, "Well,
let's just do it for fun."
And so we made one.
>>Dawn: Oh, you know what,
do they have like a beach
or something like that?
>>Travel, try travel, what's travel?
>>Oh, that's what I'm
talking about, right there.
That's where I wanna be.
>>I consider myself relatively
savvy when it comes to computers
and cell phones and things like that.
But I have to say that Olivia
introduced me to a whole new world.
>>Olivia: Oh my god, what?
Oh.
>>Dawn: See, that's
where I'd like to be.
Oh my god.
How do you do that?
That's ridiculous that
you're so fast.
I can't possibly.
My thumbs don't work like that.
>>Many other kids, they
just have that access.
They have their own computer at home.
They can do that.
They can go to school
and use computers
and have teachers that'll tell them
how to do these kinds of things.
But she's really done a
lot of this on her own.
>>All right, let's
see what you sent me.
What did you say, Olivia?
"When are we gonna
see an R rated movie?"
>>She didn't have her own
computer, but what she would do is,
she would go to the Apple
store and she would, you know,
take her photos there that she
would post on her MySpace page,
and she'd update it there.
>>Olivia: Cheese.
>>My cell phone, I use
it almost every second
of the day when I'm not in school.
>>Yeah, so just call me back, right?
Bye.
>>I use MySpace on my phone,
just to check if I have messages.
My iPod is important to me.
I thought I would never have
one, but I got it given to me
from the Big Brothers,
Big Sisters event.
>>I got about 284 songs
on here, mixed oldies,
reggae tone, R and B, rap.
>>I think it's just like my life
'cause I feel like if I don't got it,
I'm like off track, or
I don't have a good day,
because I need music to keep me up.
My neighborhood, it's a lotta
drugs going on over there.
My mom wants to get out, but
it's kinda hard in the situation.
>>Romi: Take a picture, take it?
>>Olivia: The people that live with
me is my mom, my older brother,
my grandma, my two younger siblings.
>>Romi: Here, hold
the dog right there.
Big household, little apartment,
but at least we have an
apartment to live in.
>>And you always press this
one right here on the side.
That'll take you straight
to the photo gallery.
>>Boy: Here, give it to me.
>>Olivia: The computer in the
basement is used for anybody
that lives in the building.
>>Girl: And let me
see your boyfriends.
>>Olivia: They're there from
nine in the morning till six.
>>Girl: MySpace too, okay?
>>Olivia: Here, click on this.
>>When I'm downstairs on the
computer at home, I'll probably spend
about four, maybe five
hours, either searching
up something I found
interesting on MySpace, or emails.
>>Dawn: Olivia has, up to
this point in her life,
been incredibly resourceful, not
just when it comes to learning
about technology and learning
how to get to technology,
but really overcoming obstacles.
And I think that that's
just gonna translate,
and I think she's just
gonna do great things.
>>Woman: It's my great honor to
present Big Sister Dawn Kruger
and her Little Sister Olivia.
>>Olivia: Because of the support
I have gotten over the years,
I am now in the top
three at my high school.
>>[cheers and applause]
>>Olivia: And just last
week, I got the great news,
I passed my high school exit exam.
[cheers and applause]
>>Dawn: I have to say, after seven
and a half years, I
have learned a lot.
>>I've learned what MySpace is
and how to communicate on it.
>>I've learned how to communicate
by text message and by doing that,
I learned what acronyms like LOL
and OMG mean, and how to short just
about every word in
the English language
to three letters and or numbers.
[laughter]
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org